béchir public je suis de retour après un
séjour dans un pays gorgé d'eau oui j'ai
pour et simone avec non effectivement
mes tirs 10 ou le sait comme le disait
le christ roi il faut rendre à césar ce
qui est à césar à la mongie et bien je
te rend une fois pour toutes cette heure
si serré
bah oui tu crois qu'il est la femme la
plus extraordinaire
intouchable incontournable il vaut mieux
et sur la tienne non ça allait quand
même pas d'une corpulence tels que
cantat motocyclistes fait le tour il
établit de s'arrêter pour faire le plein
non je veux dire que c'est une femme
fantastique et alors par contre la
moquerie et j'adore j'aime bien mais
celle que j'ai lus par karl zéro pendant
des débuts str dire de toi là c'est moi
en tant que toi comme une étoile étoiles
à salzbourg toi c'est toi c'est moi qui
peut lui pardonner
non
c'était contre la traiter de [ __ ]
voilà c'est toi qu'on guimond ibrahim
fléchi tu savais d'ailleurs j'ai un
document
tu sais ce que c'est le maximum que les
années n'ont jamais tu sais qu'en ce
moment les animateurs et les
journalistes ont beaucoup de problèmes
et là j 1 j'ai un document bien embêtant
pour toi qui en 1960 tu te souviens tu
vois six mois tu as des as la banque du
sperme du boulevard le ferais souvenir
ça très bien
sûrement faire un don à don généreux
d'ailleurs mon chéri débat si tu es bien
ce qui devait arriver est arrivé
nous voilà je tombe reste
je suis tranquille a pardonné au travers
de moi pour ce par simone à la visite
rendent accord est bon
l'habitude simone hauswald
encore des glyphes restera menchov oui
on est le formidable
j'adore ce journal extrêmement drôle je
pense que c'est pour toi tu m'as lire le
scandale des pédophiles contaminé ça
t'intéresse vague
dis-moi l'info intox pas toi qui l'a
inventé ça pas du tout sauf que jacques
antoine a fait l'émission je mets juste
de te le dire
bref les dix ans il s'appelait vous faut
ouais ouais j'ai un peu le même genre
bon alors